[موسيقى]
مستخدمين مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي في كثير
من المخاطر اللي هي بتهدد بياناتهم وانهم
خصوصيتهم وحده من هاي المخاطر هي البيانات
اللي بيزودوا فيها هم بشكل طوائي مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي صورهم صور اطفالهم
وعائلاتهم والانشطه فيها جزء من الاشياء
اللي كمان ممكن يتم تسريبها عنهم هي
المعلومات اللي بتم جمعها عنهم عن سلوكهم
عن اهتماماتهم
الخطر الاخير هو حالات الاختراق اللي
بتملى مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي واللي بيتم
فيها تسريب بيناتهم عناوين بطاقاتهم
ائتمانيه على الكتروني ارقام هواتفهم او
عناوينهم كل هاي الاشياء ممكن تهدد خصوصيه
مستخدمه
[موسيقى]
مجموعه من الاجراءات اللازمه بتاخذوها
مستخدمين مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي لحمايه
خصوصيتهم انهم ما يشاركوا كم كبير من
المعلومات على موقع تواصل اجتماعي الا مع
العائله والاصدقاء ضبط الخصوصيه في
الحسابات بحيث انه ما يتم مشاركه هذه
البيانات للجمهور بشكل عام استخدام برامج
حمايه لضمان استخدام اجهزه امنه لا يمكن
اختراقها وضبط كلمات المرور للحسابات
الخاصه فيهم بطريقه قويه عدم استعمال
ارقام هواتفهم وتاريخ ميلادهم او ارقام
سهله جدا الى كلمه ككلمات مرور لمواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي الخاصه فيهم
[موسيقى]
كثير من الدول بدات ان هي تصدر قوانين
لحمايه بيانات المستخدمين في دول اشهر هذه
القوانين قانون جي تي بي ار اللي اصدر
واتحاد الاوروبي لحمايه بيانات مستخدمين
الاوروبيين وعدم تتبعهم وعدم مشاركتهم
بياناتهم مع التطبيقات او اقراص واحد من
قوانين مهمه جدا هو كان قانون كوبر الذي
تم اصداره في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لحمايه بيانات يستخدمون مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي والانترنت اللي بتقل اعمارهم عن
13 سنه وتم تطبيقه بشكل كثير واضح في
اليوتيوب هنالك الكثير من القوانين التي
تصدر في عدد من الدول التي تفرضها على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي والشبكات التقنيه
الكبرى لمنع استغلال بيانات مستخدمين هذه
الدول
[موسيقى]
الدور الاهم هو دور الشركات اللي هي يجب
ان تلتزم تطبيق القوانين وعدم مشاركه
البيانات مع اطراف ثالثه وحمايه البيانات
من الاختراق للاسف خلال السنوات الماضيه
شاهدنا كثير من الانتهاكات شركات مثل ميته
جوجل وتيك توك وغيرها بتهكت هذه القوانين
سربت بيانات المستخدمين تعرضت لعمليات
اختراق وتعطل لتسريب البيانات عرضت
لغرامات كتير كبيره قد تصل احيانا في باب
غرامات
510% من ايرادات هذه الشركات لكن للاسف ما
زلنا الا الان نرى انه هاي الانتهاكات
تتكرر بشكل دائم وبيانات المستخدمين ليست
في امان عمان
[موسيقى]
في بعض الحالات قد تساهم بعض الشركات في
تسهيل عمليه الاختراق عندما تلجا بعض
الشركات الى تخزين بيانات شخصيه مستخدمين
دون موافقتهم ولا تتبع ممارسات امنيه قويه
لحمايه بيانات المستخدمين من الوصول فان
هذه الشركات قد تكون ساهمت بشكل او باخر
في تسهيل عمليات الاختراق اضافه الى ان
بعض الشركات قد تلجا الى تسهيل عمليه
الاختراق عن طريق بيع بيانات المستخدمين
الى اطراف ثالثه غير موثوقه ويتم الاختراق
عن طريق هذه الاطراف الثالثه